>>> Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome vice
president of engineering for Google, Vic Gundotra.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Well, good morning, everybody.
You made it, even at this early hour.
I hope you enjoyed that party last night.
How --
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yeah?
How about that spider?
Was that cool or what?
After a few drinks, I thought that thing was
going to chase me.
A lot of fun.
Let me also welcome the many thousands who
are watching our live stream on YouTube.
Yesterday, just for your information, we had
over 24,000 people watching it concurrently
live.
So in addition to the 5,000-plus folks we
had here, we had almost 30,000 watch us yesterday.
So welcome to everyone watching on YouTube.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: To begin today's keynote,
I'd like to start with a story.
It's a story of my very first day on the job
at Google.
Now, I'm sure you've all been at a new job.
You understand the apprehensiveness you might
feel with a new office, new people.
It was on that very first day that I met a
man named Mr. Andy Rubin.
Now, I suspect most of you know who Andy Rubin
is.
At the time, he was responsible for what was
then a secret project code-named "Android."
And on that first day, Andy enthusiastically
described to me the team's mission and purpose.
And as he spoke, I'll level with you, I was
skeptical.
In fact, I interrupted Andy.
And I said, "Andy, I don't get it.
Does the world really need another mobile
operating system?
Google's about advertising.
Shouldn't we be on every phone?"
To this day, I remember Andy's response.
And he made two points.
The first point Andy made was that it was
critically important to provide a free mobile
operating system, an open source operating
system, that would enable innovation at every
level of the stack.
In other words, OEMs should be free to build
all kinds of devices, devices with keyboards,
without keyboards, with front-facing cameras,
two inches, three inches, four inches, that
operators should be able to compete on the
strength and coverage of their network, 2G,
3G, 4G, LTP, CDMA.
And that in the end, with innovation coming
at every layer, it would be the consumer who
would be able to benefit by getting the best
device and best network for them.
I remember Andy's second point.
He argued that if Google did not act, we faced
a Draconian future, a future where one man,
one company, one device, one carrier would
be our only choice.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: That's a future we don't want.
So if you believe in openness, if you believe
in choice, if you believe in innovation from
everyone, then welcome to Android.
Now, let's get started.
Let's talk a little bit about the momentum
that we've achieved in 18 months.
It's been a year and a half since we've started
with Android.
How are we doing?
Let's do a little bit of a report card.
First of all, let's demonstrate some momentum.
It's hard to believe that in only 18 months,
we've achieved over 60 compatible devices,
where your software, where your applications
can run.
And these devices are not just from, you know,
people you haven't heard of.
These are from the leading consumer electronic
companies in the world, Sony Ericsson, HTC,
Motorola, and many others, who are producing
devices that meet the needs of consumers.
We think this is pretty fantastic progress
in just 18 months.
Of course, it's not just the creation of the
devices.
It's the 21 OEMs in 48 countries and over
59 carriers who have joined the Android revolution.
Of course, producing devices, making them
available across a multitude of countries
and carriers doesn't necessarily mean that
we're going to see adoption.
Have users found Android to be something that
they desire?
Well, last year, we reported, late last year,
that we had reached a sales run rate, a daily
activation rate, of over 30,000 units a day.
In February, just a few months later, we announced
that our daily run rate had achieved 60,000
units a day.
I'm very proud to announce today that our
run rate daily activations has now passed
100,000 a day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Go, Android!
Of course, that momentum has led to some pretty
significant milestones.
One of the ones we are most proud of is that
this quarter, we are now second in the United
States in smartphone sales, second only to
RIM.
And that's pretty amazing progress in 18 months.
We're second in smartphone sales, but according
to AdMob data, we are now first this quarter
in total Web and app usage.
That's fantastic.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know, we set a crazy internal
milestone for ourselves.
The phones are being used by consumers, but
what are they being used for?
And we set a crazy internal goal when we shipped
turn-by-turn navigation for Android.
We thought it might be possible to have a
half a billion miles navigated in the first
year.
In hardly six months, we've now crossed a
billion miles navigated with turn-by-turn
navigation on Android.
So users just love that feature.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: There are some who say that
users don't use Google Search on smartphones.
Well, we're a company driven by data, not
by opinions.
And you know what the data shows?
The data shows that we've seen a 5X growth
in the past two years.
That's not just on Android, but that's across
all smartphone categories.
People love Google search.
You give them a great browser, and they do
Google search, tremendous, awesome usage of
the Web on these devices.
Of course, what they love is applications.
And today I'm happy to announce that we've
crossed 50,000 applications in the Android
Marketplace.
And, really, the credit there goes to you.
Thank you, for the 180,000 developers.
Thank you.
The 180,000 developers who have joined the
Android revolution.
Really, it's your hard work that's paired
with the innovation that's coming from OEMs
and carriers that makes the mobile ecosystem
work.
We certainly couldn't have done this without
you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for supporting
Android.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, let's talk about the
platform.
We've finished the section on momentum.
Let's talk about what we're doing to make
the Android platform continue to evolve and
get better.
In this section, I have over 20 demos, 22
demos, I believe.
In order to help me with that, I'd like to
invite up on stage Matt Waddell, my partner
in crime here.
Many of you may remember Matt from last year.
And we're going to go through a number of
demos that are going to really showcase what
we're doing with Android.
There are five major areas of investments
that we're making in the platform.
Now, we've been quick to iterate with Android.
In fact, there's been seven releases in those
18 months.
And today we're announcing the next release,
Android 2.2 code-named Froyo.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: What's in Froyo?
Let's talk about five pillars.
Number one, let's begin with speed.
Now, as you developers know, the Android architecture
is one that's built upon a virtual machine,
the Dalvik virtual machine.
We think it's important.
It's a critical design decision that we made
that future-proofs your application.
We have big dreams for Android.
And part of those dreams mean that Android
will go to new places with new chip architectures.
But by having your applications write to the
virtual machine, we believe we can carry the
entire ecosystem to exciting new areas.
Of course, that only works if the virtual
machine is fast and the Dalvik VM has done
its job being fast, efficient, and automatic
and easy for developers.
But we can do even better.
We're very proud to announce that in Froyo,
we've added a JIT, a just-in-time compiler,
this gives up to two to five X speedup of
your apps on the exact same hardware.
Now, this is best demonstrated.
And let's do that.
Let's go to our first demo.
We're going to show you a game.
The game has been modified for purposes of
this demo.
You guys may know Replica Island.
Here's what we've done to modify the game.
The game now will show the frame rate that
it's rendering in the bottom right-hand corner.
If the frame rate drops beneath 30 frames
a second, the screen will Flash red.
Exact same hardware, exact same game, top
is running Froyo with JIT compilation, the
bottom is running Eclair.
We're going to introduce a crazy number of
monsters into this game.
You see the monsters keep getting added, increasing
the complexity.
You see the frame rate at the top.
As we add complexity, it starts to slow down.
You'll note there at the bottom, there are
times when we're dropping beneath 30 frame
a second and it's flashing red.
You'll note at the top, with Froyo, exactly
the same game runs much better, never dropping
beneath 30 frames a second, all because of
the JIT compiler.
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, as Android adoption has
skyrocketed, people have been taking these
devices to work.
And we've heard loud and clear from the enterprise
that they need very specific features.
Well, in Froyo, we introduce over 20 new features
designed to meet the needs of enterprise.
Let me touch on two of them.
Number one, we become Microsoft exchange friendly.
That means --
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yes, thank you.
That means things like auto-discovery, integration
with the global address book, the security
policies that are available in Exchange can
be forced upon the device.
Number two, we've added new APIs for device
management.
So you can build software that does critically
important things, like remote wipe of the
device if necessary.
And there's many, many other things that we've
added that you'll see in the documentation.
Let's talk about new services available for
developers in the SDK.
Now, one of the first services I want to talk
about is the application data backup API.
Now, if you use Android and you've gone to
another device, you know that Android will
automatically back up your applications.
In other words, you get a new device, you
log in, and your applications come along with
that.
However, what Android has not done is backed
up the data associated with those applications.
So, for example, I have a particularly favorite
application that helps me monitor my exercise
and my weight.
But when I move to a new Android device, the
application moves, but all my personal data
and history doesn't.
Starting with Froyo, we'll provide an application
data backup API that ISVs can take advantage
of and move the data along with the application.
We think that's a great feature.
In addition to that, we have a brand-new API,
a cloud-to-device messaging API.
Let me be clear, this is not a push notification
API designed to compensate for the lack of
basic functionality like multitasking in the
operating system.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: We've done something very
clever I think you're going to love.
As a developer, you can send a message to
our servers which will do very smart things,
like collapse similar messages, our servers,
which will optimize for the latency of mobile
networks and make sure that that message gets
down to the device.
But that's only the first step.
We've done deep integration with Android such
that when you send a message, that message
can trigger an Android intent.
Let me show you how powerful this is.
Let's go to a demo.
Now, what Matt has on the screen here on his
laptop is Google Maps.
He's -- in Google Maps -- and he's using the
Chrome browser.
And he's added a Chrome extension.
The Chrome extension is in the upper right-hand
corner.
That sends it to his phone.
In the map, he has directions, he has directions
from the Moscone Center to Google headquarters.
And he wants to send that to the phone.
What do you think happens?
Do you think we send a text message that says,
"This is the address"?
Do you think we send an e-mail?
No.
We send Android intent.
In other words, when he says send to phone,
the message gets sent to our server, gets
pushed down to the device.
The device kicks into navigation mode automatically.
Keep your eye when he clicks on "send to phone,"
keep your eye on the Android device.
So send it to phone.
And on the Android device, boom, right into
navigation.
How hot is that?
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: That's how you do a device,
cloud-to-device API.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let me show you another example.
You're reading an article on the desktop.
You think it's awesome, but you're out of
time and you need to run.
You want to keep reading that on the Android
phone.
Why don't you send that to the device, Matt.
To the device.
Opens up the browser, takes you right to that
article, not ever having to press any other
keys.
Isn't that great?
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: We can't wait to see what
you're going to go do with this API.
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
You're going to love this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I mean, come on.
If you're like me, you have a plethora of
devices you carry around with you.
And that -- all those devices shouldn't mean
added complexity and yet another bill.
Right?
You should be able to, at the platform level,
enable tethering.
And so now your Android device can in fact
become a portable hot spot and really serve
the needs of these other devices that you
might have with you.
In fact, let's show you a demo of this working.
Matt has a Nexus One running Froyo.
He'll go right into tethering and portable
hot spot.
He'll enable the hot spot.
He'll give it a name.
In fact, I think he's already named this as
Android AP.
And that hot spot will turn on.
We'll give it a second there.
There we go.
Tethering hot spot is now active.
Now he'll go to another device that doesn't
have connectivity.
How about that iPad?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And there you go.
One bill.
Isn't that beautiful?
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, it turns out, do you
know what the most popular thing people do
with these smartphones?
What do you think it is?
It's fairly obvious.
Is they actually use the phone.
Number two thing they do is, they do text
messaging.
And the third most-used application is the
browser.
And so it's critically important for us to
make the Android browser rock.
And we're going to constantly improve that
browser.
And Froyo is a major step in that direction.
What have we done in Froyo?
Well, I think you're going to love this.
We have a two to three X performance in the
browser?
How?
We took the same JavaScript interpreter that
we had in Chrome that made Chrome so fast,
V8, and we brought that into Froyo.
Now, the best way to show you how much of
an advance we've made is to do a demo.
So let's go and show you this fantastic performance
boost.
Now, we're going to do this demo with a number
of devices.
We're going to do it --
>>> Two devices.
>>Vic Gundotra: We're going to do this demo
-- three devices.
We're going to do this demo with Froyo, Eclair,
and an iPad.
Now, here's the demo we're going to do.
There's an industry-standard test, in fact,
there's -- it's a suite of 26 tests, the SunSpider
test, that really exercise JavaScript performance
of all kinds.
And when Matt presses "start" across these
three devices, we're going to exercise each
one of these 26 tests.
As we complete one test, that little Android
robot will take one breast stroke forward.
And as all 26 tests are complete, we're going
to complete an entire lap.
How are we going to go do here?
Let's go ahead and start this test.
Let's what happens.
Oh, you started the iPad first, trying to
give it a little bit of a lead here, huh?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You can cheer.
It's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I really wonder if we'll be
able to get that in the app store.
It's a Web app, how great is that?
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
We think with the performance improvements
that we just showed you that we can claim
that Froyo has the world's fastest mobile
browser. And that's a pretty great accomplishment,
one we are extremely proud of. We're not done.
I showed you what's in Froyo, but make no
mistake about our commitment to maintain leadership
in the browser on Android. And one of the
ways we are doing that is to have standards
bodies to enable Web developers to get capabilities
that were formerly only limited to the native
access to the platform.
What kind of capabilities? Think about the
kinds of things you can access on a device,
things like the magnetometer, the accelerometer.
Think about things like the camera or being
able to access speech. Wouldn't this be great
if you could access this from the browser.
We are going to show you a sneak peek at something
beyond Froyo, an early development build that
will give you a flavor of where we're going
next.
Let's go back to demos.
Now, remember, we already got some of this
work under way. Last year we worked with the
standards committees to introduce geo location
into the browser, and today almost in all
major modern platforms, you can make an API
call from the browser, get location with the
user's permission, and then do a feature like
My Location right within the browser.
But we want to do more. How about the accelerometer.
What about access to tilt in the direction
of the device?
Watch this.
Isn't that great? Right within the browser.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right.
Now, another key feature that we have heard
from developers that they want access to in
the browser is the camera.
Here, for examples the Buzz Web application.
We'd love to not only post a Buzz but we would
love to be able to include a picture. How
do you access the camera from the Web browser?
In this development build we built those APIs
right into the Web browser such that Matt
can now simply select, if he wants to -- and
it looks like in this case this demo is not
going to work. We will give it one shot, and
we will move on if it doesn't work -- but
you can access that camera capability right
from within the browser.
And we will show you that in the sandbox later.
It's great.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let's talk about another capability
that's available.
But before we talk about that capability,
let me remind you of what's possible in Android.
Google, starting about several years ago,
really made a deep investment in voice recognition.
We recognized that the mobile device, because
of its limited input capability, would be
the platform in which people used voice input
more than any other platform.
In fact, we see a stunning number of queries
being done on mobile devices where the input
is a human voice.
Now, just as a reminder of how fantastic our
capability has become over the past two years,
let me do a few demos. Or more accurately,
Matt, why don't you highlight a few cases.
>>Matt: Pictures of Barack Obama with the
French President at the G8 summit.
>>Vic Gundotra: That's a tough one. Boom!
Look at that!
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Because this is so fun, let's
do a few more.
>>Matt: Pictures of the Golden Gate Bridge
at sunset.
>>Vic Gundotra: These are queries you are
likely not to type in let alone get a response
back in a few seconds. Isn't that great?
And one more.
[ Applause ]
>>Matt: Del Dotto Vineyards, Napa.
>>Vic Gundotra: My favorite vineyard in Napa.
Boom.
What Matt just showed you was phenomenal voice
recognition that we are now shipping in Japanese,
English, a number of languages, and that's
constantly increasing, but what is coming
next is the also the ability to understand
human intentions. We will give you a very
simple sneak peek at the kinds of things we
are going to enable.
>>Matt: Call fifth floor restaurant.
>>Vic Gundotra: So in this case, because he
said "call," it got a trigger. And there are
many, many more intentions we are going to
build in and make it very, very simple for
to you use voice input as a first class way
to interact with your Android device.
>>Matt: Vic, we have got it.
>>Vic Gundotra: Let's go back to the camera
and see if this thing works. This is a Web
app. It's a Buzz Web app. There is the camera.
From the browser, boom! Right into the camera.
Isn't that great? And now you can post a picture
and give Web developers the same type of capabilities
you would expect in a native application.
Glad that worked. No need for you guys to
visit the sandbox.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Getting back to the speech
demonstration, what we showed you was capability
that we make available to developers, but
what about accessing that capability from
the browser? Here is a Web app.
It is a translate app from Google with one
new feature. You will note the microphone
right there at the top. Matt, if you could
just point to the microphone. There it is.
And watch what Matt does.
>>Matt: Can you help me find the nearest hospital?
>>> (repeating in French).
>>Vic Gundotra: Awesome! Awesome!
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right. Let's go back to
slides.
Now, we're not only committed to making sure
that Android -- You can clap. I will let you
clap.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know, I love it when I
don't even have to speak to a slide and we
just get applause.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I am so tempted to go on.
But let me just make a point here. We are
not only committed to having the world's fastest
browser. We're committed to having the world's
most comprehensive browser.
It turns out that on the Internet, people
use Flash!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And part of being open means
you are inclusive, rather than exclusive.
And you are open to innovation.
You know, this was driven home to me very
powerfully when my daughter picked up my iPad
and went to her favorite Web site, Web site
nickelodeon, and this is what she saw on the
iPad.
Can we switch to the iPad? A sea of orange!
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: She said, "Daddy, can I play
with your Android device?" And this is what
she saw.
The full nickelodeon site. Isn't that great?
That's what openness means.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And by the way, a special
thanks to Adobe for their incredible willingness
to work with us, engage with us on Android
and in chrome and in many other areas. It's
really fun to work with other folks in the
ecosystem to meet the needs of users.
Much nicer than just saying no.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right. Let's go back to
slides.
Now, we have also made significant improvements
in the Android Marketplace.
We listened carefully to the feedback we have
gotten from developers and from users, and
I think you are going to like the enhancements.
Let's talk about what we have done on average,
our data shows that our users are installing
more than 40 apps on their Android device,
so finding those apps is a challenge. Also
they want to search within the data of those
apps, they want to move those apps to the
SD card, and they want to update all without
having to update each individual app by themselves.
Let me show you through a series of demos
what we have done here. Let's go to demos.
The first demonstration we are going to show
you is just searching the apps. Now with the
Quick Search box we make it trivially easy
to scope it to apps. As soon as you start
typing a letter, the app you are looking for
just comes up.
It's a simple and easy way to go find apps.
Not only can you find apps, but we have improved
the Quick Search box so developers can plug
into the search framework. In that case that
icon is for Mint. Mint is a financial application,
and now you are searching within the data
of that application bringing up your financial
records.
We think developers are going to extend this
in all sorts of exciting ways, making not
only Android more usable, but their own applications
be surface, discoverable, and more fun and
engaging for the user.
Another issue we have heard is people want
to take advantage of the openness of Android,
the ability for you to plug in an SD card
with arbitrary amounts of memory. And they
want to move apps not just in the internal
memory but off to the SD card.
Two points. We've enabled that capability
in a secure way with Froyo, but we have also
made it so the user never has to worry about
it. When they install an application, we will
intelligently look at the space and if appropriate,
move it to the SD card. If the user wants
to get involved and manually move things around,
that's what this demonstration shows. In this
case, Matt is going to take a brand-new game,
Need for Speed, and he is going to shift that
game from the internal memory onto the SD
card. There you go. The whole 50 megabytes
is being moved over. Why don't we just start
the game. Why don't you launch that game.
You can see it's on the SD card.
Why don't you launch that game. Isn't that
awesome? Great new game, Need for Speed, and
it can live on your SD card.
Okay. Let's move on.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Matt, Matt, we have got to
go. I know the game is fun.
All right. Let's go into the marketplace and
talk about....
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right. Let's talk about
update all functionality.
Matt, that's you.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: He is easily distracted.
All right. Today, you have to update each
application individually. In Froyo, we have
made it simple. At the bottom of the Android
Marketplace you see the update all button.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I am kind of embarrassed you
have to clap on that. We're glad it's there.
We have gone one step further with Froyo.
Why should the user have to take any action?
Starting with Froyo, with the user's permission
you can allow automatic updating, and all
your apps are updated all the time. Isn't
that great?
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And the user doesn't have
to worry about this at all.
Let's go back to slides.
Another key feature we're adding in Froyo
is designed to meet the needs of developers.
We want the best apps on Android, the highest
quality apps. And that means we need to close
the loop when there's a problem.
Let's go back to a demonstration here, and
I am going to show you an app called crashy.
It does exactly that really well. Matt, why
don't you start the app, and it crashed.
Note there's a button there called Report.
The user can press Report, can provide a description
of what happened. They can look at all the
data they are going to send, make sure they
are comfortable with that data and they can
hit send. And that is sent back to the developer.
Note on this screen the Android Marketplace,
note a brand-new tab, "Bugs." And when you
click on bugs we will show you those reports
for your application, and we will show you
the entire stack trace of what happened.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: We thought you might like
that. And closing the loop, allowing apps
to get better and better.
All right. Let's go back to slides.
I want to go a little bit beyond Froyo and
show you a sneak peek at other exciting things
that we are doing in the Android Marketplace.
I think you are going to like some of these
things. Let's go back to demo.
Matt is now showing you the Android Marketplace,
except this is unlike anything you have ever
seen before. It's the Android Marketplace
accessible from a browser on a PC, and that's
great.
Matt can browse apps, he can look at reviews,
but you will look up in the upper right-hand
corner, Matt is signed in, and because he
is signed in, we know every Android device
that he has.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yeah, he is a little weird.
In this case, the device that he has on the
stage, he has selected at nutter butter, nutty
buddy, something. Like I said, he is weird.
He has got his phone selected, and so now
he can go browse a particular app. He is going
to find an app he likes like Open Table. Hold
on, hold on Matt. He is going to hit free
and he is going to go and download the app.
What do you think happens? Let's see, what
happens today on some other systems. You find
the app, you download it to your PC or Mac.
You then have to tether your device. Once
it's on your PC, you have to then convert
it over that tethering to your device and
then make that sync happen. Well, guess what?
We discovered something really cool. It's
called the Internet.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And when Matt presses download,
keep your eye on the Android device.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Over the air.
Isn't that totally great? Over the air, installed
on your device.
Now, it turns out it's called the Android
-- or the Marketplace because it's more than
apps. In fact, what we are about to show you
is a new category.
How about some music?
Matt, why don't you find an album or song
you like, and why don't you just send it to
the device using the Internet, over the air.
And boom, keep your eye on the Android device.
There you go. There is the music coming right
on down.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, we're not done yet. Some
of you may be thinking this is really cool,
this is so hot, but I have my music already
on my device at home, my Windows media or
my iTunes library. I have thousands of songs
there. What do I do with those?
We recently acquired a company called Simplified
Media and it is our intention to incorporate
that technology into the marketplace as well
and that allows you at home to run a simple
piece of hardware that makes all your non-DRM
music available to your Android device. Would
you like to see this? Let's go to your Android
device.
Android device has two songs on it. That's
nice, but I want more than two songs. I want
all my music I have.
So Matt will go down and select -- I guess
he has to plug in the device so you can hear
it.
>>> Options, touch nine. Thank you for calling
the fifth floor restaurant.
>>Vic Gundotra: My God!
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let me offer a public apology.
Now.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know what's really odd?
Is that they didn't pick up all that time.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Wow!
Getting back to music. Two songs. I want all
my music. He is going to select that button
that says all, and magically, all the music
is now available.
Now, you might be wondering what just happened?
We are making your whole music library available
to your Android device as a stream. So, for
example, if Matt was to select a particular
song, I guess Matt's an Earth, Wind and Fire
fan, hit play. Will this work?
(music playing).
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yeah, we think users are going
to love this feature.
All right. Let's go back to slides.
Let's talk a little bit about advertising.
It turns out that we know a little bit about
advertising. Today happens or this year happens
to be Google's tenth anniversary of providing
advertising solutions. And we have learned
a few things in that decade.
One of the foremost things we have learned
is if you want to have a healthy ecosystem
of advertising, you need advertisers. And
we have hundreds of thousands of them.
That means if you have an ad spot, we have
a relevant ad that can fill it. It's called
inventory.
We're not new at this game. We're not working
with a handful of partners and charging them
a million dollars each to be a part of our
program.
Okay? So we can be your advertising partner.
We have also learned something else in that
decade. That advertisers and accomplishers
have different kinds of needs.
There are local advertisers, there's direct
response advertisers, there are brand advertisers.
And if you want to play, you need formats
that meet the needs of those kinds of advertisers.
And we have those formats.
A third thing that we have learned, advertising
needs to be measured. And that means it needs
to have great tools.
Why does it need to be measured? Well, you
need to know if the money you are spending
is giving you a return on the investment.
You need to know which campaigns are working
so you can invest more in them or tweak them
as necessary.
And it turns out that we have some tools you
might have heard of called DoubleClick, analytics,
AdSense, AdWords? The tools the industry knows
and loves are being used seamlessly to work
in the mobile environment.
And finally, we know it's important to be
open to innovation.
Now, I don't even know what the ponies have
to do with this slide, but part of being open
is when you get a designer who gives you a
slide, you go with it.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let's show you each one of
these four points and go to demos.
Now, these are real advertisers and real applications.
Let me make that point clear. You are looking
at Backgrounds. One of the most popular applications
available in the Android Marketplace.
At the top, you are looking at a Google ad.
Our ad program, which has been available only
to a limited number of beta participants,
is called AdSense for Mobile Apps, AFMA, and
you are looking at one of those AFMA ads.
You are looking at our large inventory of
text ads being optimized and served on that
device. We are taking advantage of the small
space we have and you are seeing the nice
rotation. That's just one ad format. What
happens if Matt selects something like beaches?
Then we can serve a contextually relevant
ad. In this case, Kayak is a popular Web site,
an application for travel. But in this case
when you click on the ad, we take you to deep
within the Android Marketplace so the user
can download the app. That's another important
ad format.
Let's show you another format.
This is a third format for brand advertising.
In other words, a banner ad where an advertiser
has decided to convey their message through
an image. We support that.
How about another category, and this is something
that we are announcing available today, and
that's an expandable ad format.
One of the things that we have seen through
our research is that users, if at all possible,
would like to stay within the context of the
application they are using.
So in this case, when Matt selects that Volkswagen
ad, it expands right out, you can look at
that ad and when he is done with it he can
simply make it slide right back in.
We think that's great for advertisers, and
we think that's great for users.
That expandable format is available today.
Let me show you another brand-new one we are
making available today. This is an expandable
ad format. This is a Flixter application.
Why don't you expand that ad out. In this
case it's not just display; it's rich media.
He is linking directly to a trailer. He clicked
on it and the trailer will begin and the movie
will go ahead and start.
Matt, don't watch the movie. Let's come back.
Let me show you another ad format. This is
also an expandable ad format, but in this
case, this expandable ad format has -- I'm
sorry, in this case -- I jumped ahead of you.
Let's go back to the other one.
In this case I am going to show you a very
popular ad format that has been testing incredibly
well. This is a click-to-call ad.
In this case we are leveraging the fact that
the user has given us permission to use their
location. We know that they are in San Francisco,
and DirecTV would like to make a special offer
to customers in San Francisco and they have
a new click-to-call option. So simply clicking
on that button on that ad allows the customer
to make that phone call to DirecTV, and that's
incredibly valuable.
Let me talk about another format. This is
an expandable format with a clever twist.
Matt, expand that one out. It includes a map
and directions and click-to-call. Isn't that
great? That's a new format that will become
shortly available as well.
Okay. Finally, let me show what you I meant
when I said open to innovation.
This is the weather.com application, and they
are using the industry standard DoubleClick
software to serve this ad from Google.
The ad is at the bottom.
Now, when Matt clicks on that ad, you get
a full screen immersive ad, and it's a pretty
amazing ad. It's got trailers and TV spots
and galleries. Not only does it have a bunch
of media you can interact with, look at the
bottom there. The bottom has the ability for
you to tap directly into fandango to purchase
movie tickets.
But do you know what the kicker is of what
you are seeing? It's not a Google ad. You
are seeing an immersive ad format delivered
by a great advertising company called MediaLabs.
But because the advertiser -- excuse me the,
ISB, the developer used DoubleClick to serve
the ads, DoubleClick is open to have any ads
show up. And that's what it means to be open.
That we serve the most relevant ad to the
user, sometimes from Google, sometimes not,
but you the developer and the publisher have
the choice.
If would you like to learn more about our
advertising solutions, we encourage you to
go to google.com/mobileads.
And we are opening up AFMA, AdSense for Mobile
Apps, to everybody at the conference, all
5,000 of you.
And we're going to sweeten the deal a little
bit.
If you go sign up, we will give you $100 free
advertising credit to start learning the system
and advertise your apps in the Android Marketplace.
So, please, go try that out.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: One of the most powerful ways
to demonstrate what I talked about at the
beginning, that innovation comes from all
levels of the stack, is to highlight one of
my favorite devices.
This is the device by HTC.
It's the EVO device.
Now, there are several things I love about
this device.
One thing I love about the device is, its
absolutely gorgeous 4.3-inch screen.
I also love how fast it is.
I love the great work HTC has done to add
value.
I love the Sprint network.
It's a 4G network.
You know what a 4G network can do?
It can give you a peak of 10 megabits per
second.
Imagine what you can watch on this device
at 10 megabits per second.
I love the fact that this device has a great
little stand.
You can set it on the desk, or if you're on
an airplane, just set it right there and watch
your content.
It's got a great battery.
It's got HDMI output.
It's got a camera that's 8 megapixels and
that will do 720p HD video recording.
And you know what I love most about this device?
Is that in partnership with Sprint and HTC,
Google is going to make this device available
to every one of you today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, for those of you who
are watching on YouTube, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Remember to register next
year, quickly.
I think you're going to love that device.
We ask you to do two things.
Number one, don't run out right now.
After the keynotes are over, we're going to
make it available all day until 6:00 p.m.
So you'll have plenty of time to get this
device and really get to see the latest in
Android innovation.
Number two thing we're going to ask.
Thank you for supporting Android.
Thank you for voting on the side of openness
and choice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Please keep building those
great apps.
Now, we're at the halfway point this morning.
We're not done yet.
If you'd like to see the next step in the
evolution of Android and where we're about
to go next, hang tight.